Hannah Hannah thank you thank you very
much indeed can I just say I know
perfectly well why you're all here
there is no bloody index in this book
you've all come to try to see whether
you're in it and we will get every
single one of you later on I discover
doing my final reading of it this
afternoon that I am in it on page three
two thousand six hundred and seventy-one
sure there's only two thousand people
per slighting reference to how much I
earn or don't earlier paired with you
which we might come back to later and in
fact I was walking my dog in the park
this morning this guy came out to me and
said why do you write these fawning
articles about John Humphrys for all the
time he said oh you're being paid a lot
and I said well yes I am
exactly when he was rather crestfallen
and and and went away anyway it is a
real pleasure to be doing this we will
have a conversation which will last four
minutes yeah if I'm Enzo babe we might
stretch it out to fifty we will leave
plenty of time though for questions I
know a lot of people here have come to
ask questions
I'm sure Eddie Mayer's somewhere in the
audience and possibly some people have
read the book then and some others may
well be here who want to and and for a
small fee I'll come to you right at the
John I got up at quarter past three this
morning and you did not know which feels
like what bliss it doesn't does it
no you must miss it yes there must be
something about it yes what ask any more
questions what aspect oh I miss arguing
this is true this is true a few days ago
a frog in my garden jumped into the I
found the frog in the sink in a sink you
knows from the pipe comes down from the
roof and
the wastewater flows out and they sink
and there was a frog in the sink and it
couldn't get out no because it was not
so I helped it out I put my hand in and
I scooped it up and as I did so it
started doing what dogs do it go and I
started arguing with it and I don't know
no John that's it you know it's only
been a fortnight what the hell is going
to be like yeah I mean what else can you
do when you get up apart from our queue
I mean do you listen to it which answer
do you want Justin now the honest one
the honest one I listen to the headlines
to see if anything important has
happened and I listen to see who you've
got on and on that basis I decide and I
reckon it's probably about 50/50 but
maybe I'll have it on in the background
and when you listen do you do what
everyone I imagine here does oh yeah why
the hell isn't the asking that for God's
sake yes yeah yeah and the number of
times I've gone for my phone to text the
editor say that is funny can't possibly
and then the finger is poised over the
person then you realize that that and
that one's yes when Nick's on that's
yeah I'm not going to call I can I'm
allowed to comment now on time nothing
is stopping me I have freedom so no it's
not only when Nick's on do you that that
was fairly diplomatic wasn't it to to
diplomatic people may feel and we might
come back to that do you have this kind
of sense though of freedom yes that
which has what impact on you on your on
your life not very much at the moment
but I'm working towards it because I've
got another book coming out in about six
weeks in which I say what I really think
yeah it's it's taken middle of the world
to adjust not well I think the honest
truth is not very much because having
done the book I mean I've said in the
book pretty much what I think about
there and it was weird
starting the book because I'd actually
sign
the contract to do the book nine years
ago promised to deliver within two years
and then finally got around to writing
it starting to write it about eight or
nine months ago so instead of having
seven years in which to write it I had a
few weeks and a few months in which to
write it and the first few sentences are
right but instinctively I thought I know
what they'll think about that
because you do don't you I mean however
what old hands like us however I mean
you're a bit older than me but you do
you there is just a little bit of your
brain as you've been with the
corporation as I have for fifty years
you've all even though occasionally
quite often you might defy the bosses
but nonetheless in the back of your
brain there's that little red warning
light that says should you really be
saying that and now you don't have to do
that but are the things you want to say
I mean more things that might seriously
not be in the book that you wanted you
find yourself now having views in a way
that you've kind of repressed for well
yes I mean not having views I think I've
always thought what I think if you see
what I mean but but haven't said it but
brexit is the obvious example isn't it I
mean I towards the end of my time there
well fact for the past three years I
suppose I was given an awfully hard time
by many members of the Twitterati if
that's what they're called for being a
brexit here and giving a horribly hard
time to remain errs which was can I use
the word in this is sort of almost the
sacred building isn't but nonetheless
which was bollocks I mean I didn't know
and now no lightning as I yeah no I'm
just looking out there there is an old
fellow with a long beard with a bolt or
something and and and now I am able to
say I voted remain and now obviously I
could
there you go but but I couldn't say that
I mean how did you vote Justin
luckily I'm still on the corporation and
I refuse the glass of wine before we
started I noticed so I'm not foolish
enough to say but let me put this to you
on the remain subject you told me that
quite soon after the after the
referendum milk it's also become obvious
when you read the book you are a
remainer yep you are an atheist you are
a Republican I mean move to Islington
for God so what kind of a social
conservative are you why is it that
everyone has got this wrong about you
because you know you're not a proper
representative of all the things that
you sort of claim to be representing it
seems to me Oh
are you sure about that I'm pretty sweet
way we make fairly sweeping judgments
about who our brexit is and who our
romaine is to sweetie and ridiculously
simplistic judgments and there are
plenty of perfectly thoughtful perfectly
intelligent perfectly worldly wise
people who see no reason why we should
not leave the European Union that's just
one illustrate Republicans I what I
actually said was I think was that the
Queen obviously
is doing the job and I did I you can't
say anything much other than that can
you
in truth I mean I've in your first book
well no but even if the seventh and
eighth book the faculty is the idea of
getting rid of the Queen at this stage
in our history is simply bonkers simply
bonkers
nobody buh-ba-ba-bah whopping you'd have
to have a referendum wouldn't you and
how many people would vote to get rid of
the Queen 1% 2% I don't know but it
would be tiny there's between that and
saying I'm Republic in the sense that I
believe and this is what I believe that
it ideally ideally shouldn't continue
now it's going to continue I know that
because that's what whether we're the
people of this country are what I would
do is a starter though it is although
this is deeply tedious because I'm sure
90% of the object anyway is its take an
entirely different approach to the royal
family as a body I can see no reason why
we should bow and scrape which is what
we do no matter how you wee
you balance great two members of the
royal family who do watch apart from
spend taxpayers money I'm not quite sure
and sometimes they represent the country
fine sometimes as they make a balls of
it sometimes they are clearly rather
nasty people with shady backgrounds and
yet we are required to revere them and
that's what gets to me when your kids
save you I haven't got any very small
kids any longer but but I can remember
when my younger kid my older kids were
growing up and I lived in the as you did
in the United States and the message to
every child in America as you know was
any kid in this wonderful country of
ours can grow up to be the head of state
of this great country you can't say that
to a kid in Britain now all right we
have a different system I've accepted
that of course it'll be childish and
silly not to have accepted that but
nonetheless I think it's about time we
took a slightly more skeptical view with
the rest of the institution because it's
flawed in my view there is a challenge
since you brought out brexit there is a
challenge to your own brexit when it's
this you write quite a lot in the book
about how the BBC didn't see it coming
management didn't see it coming
reporters didn't see it coming we didn't
get out there and not know we do and
that and that is unquestionably your
view there's a more subtle challenge to
you that I've certainly heard is that
one of the reasons we voted to leave the
European Union is that you didn't
challenge people properly on the facts
of the case in other words the arguments
that were put on each side weren't
suited by your interviewing style the
evidence the evidence
well evidence is this evidence is this
that very there are two you have to show
up for a minute there are two styles of
interview one I think
evan Davis epitomizes and you have a
little bit of a gaudium in the book kind
of gently but evan Davis epitomizes this
view that when you interview someone the
effort is to try to find what the truth
is when you interview someone your
effort is to knock them down
much as possible because you like a good
barrister trying to see test the wheels
of their case and the argument is this
is way too long a question but the
inaudible or the argument is that
actually brexit needed the first
approach not the second
well is an argument for that right I
mean oh yeah I've got to stop you now
it's time for the weather I think you've
conceded it I've actually forgotten what
the first part is who is so Lambert well
I took exception by the way to the word
truth we're not trying to seek or find
or prove the truth no no no no no no no
I say I think you're can ah ah fact yeah
but people can't it one group of people
who believe in the ideology or whatever
else and we can take a set of facts
which are indisputable facts and other
can take the same set of indisputable
facts and reach entirely different
conclusions and tell you that the truth
of the matter is X or Y that happens has
always happened throughout history and
will always happen and so I'm nervous
about the word truth who was truth do
you want do you want Donald Trump's
truth and I use the word in inverted
commas clearly when we're talking about
Donald Trump or do you want Boris
Johnson's truth or do you want jeremy
corbyn's truth they all have different
versions of the truth that's a cop-out
there is some thing they spotted it well
done there is no other thing that is
true I mean there really is there are
things that are the case about for
instance trade about for instance the
northern island border there are things
that are factually true about what is
possible and what isn't so the challenge
to you is that your style doesn't
doesn't get it nor that Northern Ireland
border good example perfectly good
example it is the case and this is
puzzle means right from the beginning it
puzzled me up to this day that after
brexit however it happens there is bound
to be a border between the United
Kingdom as exemplified by that the the
the province of Northern Ireland and the
Republic of and it has to be bought
otherwise
what would happen now the effect of that
would have is where you get into
difficulty with the truth those who are
unionists will argue that it would
destroy the Union those who are
nationalists would argue that if you do
allow the border to be recreated it is
inevitable that there will be the it
will destroy the the Good Friday
Agreement there will be violence and the
whole thing will fall apart will come
apart at the seams now those are two
versions of what they would regard as
the truth I don't know which of those is
true I've absolutely no idea so all you
can do and you were almost right in your
laborious question you know all you can
do is try to establish the facts but
then again whose facts do you want do
you want Boris Johnson for instance do
you believe Boris Johnson when he says
that in the case of the Northern Irish
border you there is an indisputable case
to be made for operating the border
electronically or eight miles away from
where the border happens to be of
finding a way of doing it technically
that isn't in operation at the moment
but would work perfectly well or the
view from Brussels which is that it
wouldn't work at all no effect you want
all right you brought me into submission
can we go back to where the book begins
and the Wellsprings of what it is that
that made you you and made you not only
want to go into journalism but made
you'd have the attitude that you have to
Authority and there's a there's a bit in
the book where you go to hospital you're
a young kid and there are posh doctors
tell us about that and what happened and
why that matter always it seems to me
that that matters a lot well it about
that especially if it was an example of
of my view a 15 year old 14 year old
view at the time 14 review that they
would against us that is to say rich
people middle class people were against
us the poor people it started not in my
in my hospital bed well I mean my father
was how can I put this he was a very
strong man who had very strong views who
absolutely no time for authority EB went
blind when he was a young man when he
was a kid he had got measles and managed
to escape them a bedroom where he had
being confined because in those days
when he heard music you weren't allowed
to go out because the Sun could destroy
Europe and he his mother went out
shopping my grandmother went out
shopping and he he escaped from the
house there was snow on the ground the
Sun on the snow and he lost his sight
that did something to him that did
something quite profound too because of
the way he was treated in the years that
followed that eventually managed to get
a job and in his first week there he
punched the foreman on the nose and lost
his job and never worked for anybody
again and much more seriously than that
they my small sister Christine died has
she been taken ill not a desperately
serious illness and was taken in the
hospital my parents weren't allowed to
visit her and and very soon after she'd
been taken to the hospital she died had
they been allowed to visit which they
would have been allowed to do had they
been members of the articulate middle
class big things were awfully different
a few years ago to what few years ago
seventy years ago they might have made
the difference she might have lived
because they would have spotted
ba-ba-ba-ba he never got over that he
hated Authority he was a French polisher
who if he not we needed the money God
knows but if he knocked on the door of
the ground the house and was told to go
to the servants entrance he would turn
around and walk away that's the sort of
bloke he was and and I inherited that he
did not he was a whole full bloody new
Republican he was a member of a club
where the Queen's picture was on the
wall and there was one Friday evening
when the club was absolutely full he
refused to sit in the only empty chair
beneath the Queen's portrait and he said
so when they expelled him from the I
mean that sort of thing went on all the
time when are you inheriting isn't it
formed you that point it's so obvious
from sitting in it that's the end and
and and the incident that you referred
to I was I was in hospital I just for
the day I mean I was a day pick I I had
a cyst of the base of my spine so I was
lying on the bed naked
and the day show you on this story and
the I was going to mention the sis
anyway anyway that's the consultant to
ride the grand man arrived with his
little coterie of student doctors all of
them obviously posh young white males
and and he ignored me totally ignored me
I didn't so much to say hello whatever
didn't bother with my name or anything
he just they they stood around he
pointed at me pointed that the system
said yeah probably
this young man simply um doesn't pass
enough and we've done and and what I
wanted to do was well a bunch of other
knows and and and be say actually you
know what um I got other things wrong
with me as well which are partly result
of the kind of way you live when you're
poor we didn't have an indoor toilet you
know so in anyway look that but but it
affects you may be its job and and I'm
not I am a different person from then
just in as you will have spotted no but
you are still punching that doctor on
the nose metaphysically it seems to me
from sitting next who said in fairness
they don't exist like that I think
anyone who looks or seems to you like
that doctor and perhaps a minister of
any party anyone who is in China polity
anyone who's in authority anyone who's
in cultural authority there's one of the
things that strikes me let me ask is a
question when you look at people who are
in charge there's a different group in
charge now Arthur from yes those days
yes yes you don't like them anymore dear
it's not a question of liking them we're
journalists and our sacred duty god
forbid pompous phrase but what we have
to do and it's only we who can do it in
fleet only we will do we got people out
in the streets a few yards away from
here doing it for themselves and that's
fine but we have access to power we are
able to ask the old phrase we are able
to hold power to account that is our job
and you can only do that it seems to me
if you start from the basis not as
Paxman would have it although he was
quoting with somebody else it wasn't
but as Paxman you know you assume that
have every ounce of the polish gives you
he's lying to you
why is this lying bastard lying to me
that that's that's the sort of Paxman I
don't I don't sign up to that but and I
don't use the word cynical either I use
the word skeptical we have to be
skeptical of everything pretty much
everything a politician tells us
otherwise what are we for with you there
it comes from inside you that's
skepticism that's my point
well I'm not so sure because I don't
actually think I know anyone else at the
BBC who has known that poverty that you
described or lives viscerally and that's
the difference isn't it viscerally with
that sense of disliking I don't like the
word dislike really because it does
depend on the individual you can't just
like a class and after all I'm a bird
you're a middle class for God's sake a
lot of money as you subtly pointed out
and and and and I have you know I have a
nice house and yes I am I'm one of them
now untied so and listen just in you're
a good mate you know but you're a posh
get you went to private school you know
[Laughter]
every day for the last ten year on I saw
you wearing today jeans I suppose it's
alright for your class every week yeah I
tell you I had a wonderful exchange with
Edward student who is a la a wonderful
allegedly posh of a mayor I think by a
mile by a mile but and I put a lovely
body and had a brilliant brilliant my
mother would say not actually but anyhow
quite sure yeah well well the thing is
we were talking about Christmas in
stocks and whether you were hung up
stockings or whatever for your um your
kids and I said we you know that we
always had a an empty pillowcase that
was that was the idea and and and he
said yes it was shooting us talking
and didn't when I fell about he didn't
get it I mean but but he's such a lovely
man anyway it is a weird I mean this is
a slight coldest app and it is another
weird fact about you and me since you
bring up our relationship that you
worked with my father
yes Peter Woodson who I never knew but
you worked you will know which is
righteous yeah there are people here who
of an age where he would mean something
to you yeah baggy eyes and all the rest
yeah great man but but another oddity of
us working together and I remember the
morning I told you and I it's not often
that you see him completely silent
actually but that was and I think you
were going through oh my goodness what
did I do with Peter woods in the old
days anyway roasting the father you got
a historian he didn't know who his
father was
that's the point until you were I knew I
knew yeah sort of
early early years my mother told me and
eventually I was once his wife had gone
and I and I got in touch with his his
other kids and they very kindly allowed
me to say so just so that my kid should
know but actually in a way also said I
could give him a shock it was an added
benefit right let's get to brass tacks
you rang me I think a year or so ago one
morning and you said oh bloody hell mate
I'm in trouble he said there's a tape oh
that's me and John so Paul he said and I
my instant thought was oh my god I don't
want to see that actually a turn it
turned out to be an audio tape thank
thank the Lord
yeah it's funny the way your mind works
tell us about it
no it's about it I went in at four
o'clock in the morning that Carrie
Gracie had written a letter to the BBC
accusing them justly of badly miss
serving her actually breaking the law
because they were paying her father
than they were paying males doing much
the same job even though this is the
important bit even though they had
assured her that they work I mean that
was the essence of a complaint it was
absolutely absolutely rock-solid
complaint it was slightly weird to say
the least that she was continuing to
present the program that morning because
it was a huge story obviously and
neither she nor I was able to talk about
it
because that was the ruling and weird
you know she wasn't Allah because she's
not allowed to use doves Abraham so so I
wasn't allowed because she wouldn't ask
me so it was it was a very very very
strange touch and most bosses did not
want that to happen but a couple of very
senior bosses said yeah she's got a
continued so she was and and when I went
in the first thing I had to do having
had a very quick word with Kerry was to
do what we call a prereq a pre-recorded
interview with your mate John late John
suppose he was in Washington obviously
none it's four o'clock in the morning
strictly private little chat as we you
always have before the air that we take
the piss out of each other as you know
telling with you many times and it did
and I made some Daffy drama I mean
completely I just a bit of thinking
banker I think we call it nowadays don't
we saying ah you and that much more you
don't as much of your Berber bye Bob and
all it went for about 40 seconds and we
took the mickey out of each other and
that became converted by a certain group
of people into me deriding Carrie Gracie
do Robert just insane the whole thing
went absolutely bonkers
well you tempted to refuse to present
that morning or to ask her on air anyway
I'd well what I said the night before
when they phoned me to tell me about it
and told me part of what was in the
letter which was dynamite I mean it was
a big story than a question about that
very very serious stuff and my initial
reaction was to say shorty she can't
present' and the person I was talking to
the then editor of the program said
she's gonna have to do we can't stop I
can't stop that so there we are
I didn't say no I won't do the program
on that basis and I don't think I was
tempted I don't think
and you might argue about this and I'm
not they don't matter but this I don't
think a presenter can or should exercise
power in that way because you would be I
mean if I had said no I'm not going to
present the story would have taken a
different turn it wouldn't matter about
something and I'm not sure that we
should use abuse our power in that sense
oh no no I wasn't they played the tape
on the PM program yes they did but but
some days did they tell you before they
did not because they're you're listening
at home
I'm listening at home it's quarter past
five on a Friday evening this had
happened on Tuesday I think Monday and
and I certainly hear not the tape being
played but Eddie Mair saying win and the
B be something like women in the BBC are
being forbidden from talking about their
page which is absolutely nonsense they
weren't being forbidden they were all
over the papers but they were forbidden
rightly in my view from using their
position when they were presenting a
program to make their case I mean that
is it as we might get on to the more
recent case of that in a moment but but
that is a basic basic principle of being
a presenting there is a difference
between being a presenter and being
somebody like you when you're in North
America I could say to you what do you
think of Donald Trump you could say I
think he's a wanker
I couldn't just possibly just possibly
and I could I record I don't know you
don't he he is probably the only senior
experienced knowledgeable intelligent
journalist I know who doesn't mind you
that's now going to well in the moment
but but but anyway so you heard you hear
the tape going no I did I heard Eddie
right announcing that this was going to
happen that this had happened and then
reading in in it really was as though he
were reading the announcement made by
the prime minister on the outbreak of
war or something it would very very
solidly what I said what she said what I
said in those tones that no Eddie
reserved for the most ice soft Scottish
accent yeah but but with believable
profound but with profound regret at the
same time you know that such
awful things could have happened yes now
you know and I know we're children this
that if you're going to report a story a
controversial story like that the very
first thing you do is you call the
person at the heart of the story in this
case me and you say do you want to come
on and defend yourself had they know we
shared the same room we said it's the
same newsroom they could have just
popped across war twenty yards they
could have picked up the phone
did you ever discover why they did yes I
do know why they didn't because Eddie
was determined to do it that way and
when Eddie was editing the program he
got what he wanted and he wasn't
formerly the editor of Co he was not
formally the editor but you'd never
guess it because I rang in as soon as I
heard that I rang in spoke to the editor
and said I want a right to reply because
Eddie at no point this is the whole
thing about it is that at no point did
Eddie suggest I had been joking yeah
with adjusting with Justin you're just
you know just I was not involved and
found telling the part with that with
John at no point no suggestion that it
from him that it might have been a joke
and so I felt that I should at least be
allowed to say and it was a joke
silly stupid but nonetheless you know
two old mates and we are old mates we're
old friends we've been taking the mickey
out of each other for 30 years but
there's no point they do that and then I
rang I rang the program said I want to
speak to the editor spoke to the Edit of
the program so at the end of the program
has said in the fruity language it must
be said I want to the right to reply as
it were and he said I'll call you back
in ten minutes he didn't call me back in
10 minutes so I rang again and this time
was just a teeny-weeny bit more cross
and he said I'm not allowed to let you
come on the program he's the editor now
there's only one person who could have
stopped in doing that and it wasn't one
of the big bosses because even the big
bosses didn't know what they were doing
hmm okay anyway the substance though of
it is that you were paid an awful lot
more than particularly the women but
actually that other usual as well
as well so there was some justice in it
yes yeah God was that the result of an
understanding of your worth that was
fundamental yes that'll do you corrupt
because you all arranged in those days
all of you who were the great stars
arranged your salaries with managers who
were also overpaying themselves I put it
to you and actually there was something
pretty sickening about it no I don't
agree with that at all
I'd been like you the phonic in fact I
had your job in North America for six
years and was paid the usual salary in
those days I know it was about forty
thousand quid or whatever it was came
back to Britain was asked to do the nine
o'clock news was told by management that
I'd be idiotic not to go free lad if I
didn't go freelance I'd be very silly
clubs on the staff of courses correspond
and they said you can double your salary
as you go freelance at least so I did
and I doubled my salary and then they
asked me today program and one thing on
the other I wrote a column for The
Sunday Times for which I was paid quite
a lot of money and then was stopped from
doing that and was compensated but doing
it do you know I never ever went to
management and said I want more money
yeah but that's the extraordinary thing
that she isn't it I mean that's the
thing that I wonder about I think a lot
of people wonder I was always what were
they thinking when they paid you year
after year more and more money
well it wasn't yeah I mean but slightly
overdoing it I mean I was paying earning
a lot more than you that is certainly
true but I was also doing mastermind and
that was a completely separate and and
another reason why I had been paid more
early it was because I was also doing a
program called on the record the telly
which I did for a long time and that
kind of so I was working six days a week
and and you know what it's like being a
foreign correspondent I was away from
home three or four months at a time
I reckoned this is false money I mean I
I reckoned that I'd
I earned a decent whack and if I'm to be
entirely honest I reckoned I was worth
more than somebody who come to
presenting from somewhat easier life
than I'd had with a bit less experience
than I'd had have probably never been
shot at although that doesn't mean
anything I know but nonetheless it
wasn't an easy life being reasonable but
some BBC presenters to be paid a lot
more than other cities yeah of course I
mean that that's the thing that I think
and now the BBC is is now struggling
with is being able to say and if some of
those are men and some of them are women
it can be very difficult
we'll be clear about this it is
absolutely 100 percent unjustifiable for
men to be paid more than women . but
then you have to say in the next
sentence however if the man in question
is the director general of the BBC
naturally he should be paid more than
somebody who is the director general's
secretary for instance incidentally on
that topic on that topic since we're on
the men women thing I think and I'm
allowed to say so now formally it is
outrageous that has never been a woman
director-general of the BBC a hundred
years and no woman so I I have
absolutely I have absolutely no problem
at all I mean of course women should be
paid the same as of course they should
but if somebody is doing a more
important job or is seen as presumably
Gary Lineker was seen to be attracting
about that happening Gary Lincoln 1.75
million well alright but you know these
sums don't usually government the effect
oh yeah
let me read but slightly orangutan I
want to get to what what we in the BBC
should be able to say and as you hinted
earlier on there's this massive issue at
the moment with I don't know if you know
there's a thing called Breakfast
Television
it hasn't caught on but you know among
some it is is a thing and Chetty all
said about donald trump and about racism
and the BBC if it is fair to say and i
think i can say this as
BC person got itself into a considerable
mess you met you want to try to say can
I breathe you they made a total mess of
it shambo's what should their holics
what should they what they what they
should own was pretty much actually I
think what David Jordan did David George
David Jordan been the controller of
editorial policy so his initial response
his initial response was to say as I
understand this I wasn't actually here
at the time but but as I understand it
his initial reaction was to say nothing
wrong but no reason why naga shouldn't
have said as a woman of color i suffered
in this way in that way and the other
way a bit tardy person their own
personal experiences as vital to say
that what her co-presenter dan shouldn't
have done was to then ask her the
question for her views on donald trump's
motives in saying what he had said and i
think that's right presenters it's what
i said earlier it's going back to what I
said earlier presenters are not allowed
to express views on controversial
political topics I mean so where the BBC
eventually got to was the wrong place
the wrong place in your view yes yes I
think Tony Hall they overrule well the
thing is they were so I made this point
in the book as you know the BBC has been
historically and remains I think
historically afraid of certain pressure
groups whatever they may be at the time
I mean back in the late 80s mid band and
into the 90s immigration was a huge
issue the BBC was tablet excuse me
terrified of being seen as
anti-immigration in any sense whatsoever
so they went in the opposite direction
they were terrified of being seen to be
anti brexit and they went in the other
direction we regarded people just this
not specific individuals but there was a
sense that anybody who preached the
brexit cause that we didn't even have
the word brexit ii in those days did
anybody who said it was a good idea
forbidden to lead the European or the
European you was bobbum they were
regarded as a bit loony they weren't
regarded as serious people that was the
mindset in the BBC and throughout that
we do in this case her they frightened
whose bulletin Oh obviously racial
allegations allegations there in any way
shape or form racist but what they won't
facing it seems to me they won't be what
supporters of chedi say and what what
opponents of the BBC's initial decision
say is hang on a second why is she being
prevented from saying what she wants to
say and bringing herself to it when we
know perfectly well what John Humphrys
thinks about Media Studies farming
racism and media studies are in slightly
different what you think that's the
argument I'm putting it to they they say
why the hell shouldn't she be able to
say what she says about Trump because we
know what people like
I think the serious answer that fairly
dart question is that the media studies
is a matter of monumental and importance
for those people sorry buddy knees and
soil we talked about my views on farming
yeah I think we could all agree that
healthy soil is a good thing and not
highly controversial couldn't we really
I mean I happen to think it's one of the
most important things that obviously
global warming is up there at the top
and sort of the health of our soil is a
massively massively magical so I don't
think that's too controversial but I
think to call the President of the
United she did this butthat she was she
was being invited to suggest that the
President of the United States was a
racist that is a very broad view from
the ground a slightly exaggerated but
but nonetheless that was there that was
the direction in which it was going I
think that's wrong when we get to that
stage and you can't there are some
things like racism like immigration that
that are beyond so serious and error if
it is an error as you think it is how
serious an error has the BBC made how
what potentially will come of it you
know I think the answer that is not very
much to Bill I mean I think we're
through it you know the old Alastair
Campbell line which was that for the for
the story to become a catastrophe for
the party or the government or whoever
it is for the story to come out really
really it's got a run
on the front pages I think he used to
say for 11 days or it might have been 9
I can't remember but you know that was
the kind of length span the length of a
stuff and this hasn't passed that test I
think well I don't know you may all
think people can bring it bring up a
number yeah and what we got just a few
more minutes before I throw it out to
people who have you not interviewed who
you wanted to oh that's easy that's easy
you must have I certainly have wanted to
sit there on Monday morning and Sharon
with me this morning is Her Majesty the
Queen I mean you do don't you you just
POTUS she's not in a radio car she's
Harman in this fashion let's have the
full fantasy guy that follows she
doesn't dust doesn't have to wear a
crown though
but you're just just I mean it is every
hack stream apart from the fact that she
is unique as she has met probably met
more powerful people in her life than
anybody else on the planet and have
views that are really seriously worth it
honey and there's the gossip isn't there
you know I mean it's Andrew really that
you know what I mean even yeah so so so
so that so there's that anyway anyway
what's the first question I'm assuming
that's not the first question what's the
first question to the Queen she's there
yes the ten past eight you have the news
bulletins there's a few security people
around but but typically you see
typically you're trying to frame the
interview let me say what if I'm a
Muslim what I wanted to say and and that
is to say that I very nearly got that
interview mmm how close how close well I
had an invitation of the message on my
own phone very fruity voicing her
Majesties commanded me to invite you to
one of her private lunches me so I went
obviously I do remember walking through
Bach house with the rather tall and
elegant flunky who've been sent to
welcome me to greet me to escort Nathan
and and saying slightly nervous saying I
didn't realize people like me got
invited these something and he looked
down at me
I just didn't didn't didn't didn't do a
great deal for my confidence on anyway
we have the lunch we have the lunch and
she went wee wee all then trooped off
into there but I need only four of us
guess and we went off in four foot forth
private guesses with more private yes
and then Her Majesty and His Royal
Highness and one or two others His Royal
Highness I'd had a bit of a falling out
with the casaya i he accused me once and
i used the language that he used can I
expect anyway what he said to me it's
the stories of it then said this in
Mexico on a dirt road in Mexico when
he'd left out of a police car I was in
on the car and he left him finish the
Queen was in the front car stole my
[ __ ] car not every day this train you
said and I said piss off I didn't I
didn't I didn't I did you say is he like
an argument I'm thinking of your father
yeah I don't you I I said really boldly
sorry sir ah no the Queen that you
should have seen the Queen's Express she
was she got out of her car as well at
this point and she was just telling
going anyway anyway after luncheon we
are sitting in there standing in this
little ante room where she likes to take
her coffee and feed biscuits was anyway
and I said to her I said lovely let's
take a very much indeed we might be able
to do an interview with you or some put
you know give us and she said no and
there was and then she stopped so I
thought oh well here's the you know I
can build on this and make up you know
so I I do I'd might have delivered my
prepared speech
and said um well let's just sort of
think about the various ways in which it
could be you know we could do this I
mean that we know and she listened very
patient in your company at all and she
looked at me I sigh quote verbatim look
back at the news
what what's more mr. Humphreys if one
were ever to do such a thing it would
certainly not be with you yeah yeah
that's why she is where she is in your I
suspect anyone who wants to ask anything
and we've got people who are gonna come
among you as they say in these semi
ecclesiastical circumstances they're
gonna come among you with microphones
and numbers as well quite sure were the
numbers of four to several numbers yes
there's a number though you've got yours
the wrong way around I think out there
is number blank there you go yeah right
okay number two let's let's kick off
well let's do it by numbers so we've got
someone down here who's waving it is
number one so just just a little thing
keep them brief and we'll and we'll do
one at a time because otherwise neither
John nor I will remember what the first
question was we haven't got typically we
haven't got a pen with us either go well
firstly thank you very much both of you
it was entertaining my questions about
the Iraq war I deployed there twice
served to campaign twice you in the
campaigns out there I've never really
understood the reasons as to why we went
to war there I've studied it since I've
had a bit of a privileged insight and my
conclusion is that Blair knew exactly
what he was doing
BuChE lashed out against terrorism and
commenced the Global War on Terror the
British public was conned and most
importantly mr. Humphreys Andrew
Gilligan was probably right okay well
yeah I would agree with pretty much
everything you said we went to war
because Tony Blair had promised George
Bush we would go to war we went on the
spurious basis that they had weapons
Saddam had weapons of mass destruction
which he could unleash in 40 minutes
which was complete balderdash sometime
after the end of the war only a few
weeks after the end of the war I got
invited by an unknown figure they'd do
it rather stupidly they you get a call
from a rather fruity voice saying if we
were to invite you to have lunch with a
certain figure whose name I'm not
allowed to
would you accept and you said obesity
you gotta tell me who each other anyway
the the figure turned out to be the
director of mi5 Sir Richard Dearlove and
and this is a say was shortly after the
war by which time as you know no weapons
of mass destruction had be found and I
asked the Earl of over this lunch I said
dinner I meant lunch over this lunch
whether it was true in his view bearing
in mind that he'd been briefing bread
pretty much every morning of his life
for the last several months on the
situation in Iraq whether it was indeed
true that Iraq posed a real threat to
this country and he said and and being a
frankly bashed person it's not that I'm
hung up on poshness you understand but
but but frightfully well you decide or I
frightfully well any people he said on
on any Cartesian analysis it is our view
that you Iraq would not feature in the
top and and then he said to me and how
would you members of the media this was
obviously why I'd been invited to this
lunch
private lunch how would you members of
the media reacted if we would say to you
that of course there were weapons of
mass destruction
however when Sudan realized that he was
going to be defeated he issued an order
to those weapons of mass destruction to
be destroyed so therefore we weren't
idea but fine but how would you react to
that and I said well you mean after we'd
picked ourselves up the floor because we
were laughing so much and he said yes I
rather thought you might say that and
that's the truth of it that's the truth
of it it was it was an insane decision
by any standards and well done you for
doing what you did in for pursuing it
the way you have and in the way though
that the BBC pursued it
and we all know the outcome of that
pursuit and the crisis that it
engendered in the BBC in in the long run
who won that I don't think anybody want
it because the residual distrust there
was already distrust of course between
Blair's government I was the gamble on
us in particular gambled loathes us as
you know I don't think anybody you want
that because in the end people have to
make up the minds and you've got one I'm
never doing interviews in the morning of
the Gilligan out it was it was I who did
that interview with Andrew Gilligan you
may remember 14 minutes past 6:00 on
that particular morning and I don't know
what the audience makes of it when
you're getting totally diametric claims
being made how can the audience be
expecting I think I think and perhaps
I'm wrong about this I don't think
people got a clear understanding bearing
in mind that we'd already had one
so-called inquiry into the war I don't
think people got a clear understanding
of what had happened and why
until the Chilcott report was publicly
initially or many years later snap the
BBC around but discredited immediately
discredited immediately as the
independent paternity the Daily Mail put
it the following morning big headline
whitewash and that's when you still
believe that okay totally here number
two is there someone you're with yes
thank you I like to check out the
question of the impartiality rule what
we've just been talking about underlines
the importance of it a couple of things
first of all John you mentioned earlier
on that you used to write for The Sunday
Times were asked to stop Justin you
continued to write for tribes but
basically as BBC journalists required to
be impartial on air what ground rules
are there when you're actually in print
and aligned to that LBC permits their
presenters to assign their own opinions
do you have an apology over Ben or is it
the other way round great question
it is a very good question it changed a
wee bit over the years I was allowed to
write a column so long as and it was the
main column so it got a you know a big
chunk of space in a very prominent place
in the newspaper but I was allowed to do
it on the basis that I did not offer any
opinion at all on British politics it
was a bit hazy as to what I could say
about the rest of the world bearing in
mind that I'd been a foreign
correspondent and had been expressing
opinion about apartheid in South Africa
for instance where the government of the
day the apartheid government tried to
get me recalled I was I set up a
television news bureau in Johannesburg
and and they sent the South African
government centre the msre there their
ambassador here to try to get me
recalled because I was opposed to the
government's policy and they thought
this was I was impartial obviously I was
I was failing to be impartial and the
editor of the time the the director of
news and current affairs at the time who
had the meeting that the ambassador told
me about it afterwards he said for the
ambassador what what's the basis of you
or demanding that mr. Humphreys be
withdrawn
and he said well because he's not in
favor of our regime we didn't call it a
regime of course he called it our
government and so I can't do the South
African accent very well but I will try
and and and and then he said well I I
think the rest of the world is probably
opposed to part 8 indeed we know that to
be the case so mr. Humphreys enough if
he's getting things wrong then we would
seriously consider his position to which
the ambassador said and and I quote at
least I quote my boss but he was getting
things along very he said give me an
example what is it in the first rugby
test between but between the Springboks
and the and the Lions mr. Humphrey said
the first reverse culpa he'll denies it
was not it was called back rubella
I remained in place but the general rule
was not as rigid as it subsequently
became because after Iraq as as we both
know the rules were tightened I was
stopped from writing a column complete
but following the inquiry I was not from
so everybody was stopped from writing
for the newspapers completely it was
just a blanket ban now it's eased to the
extent that we are able to write some
stuff we have to run it past the you
know the one of the Syria editorial
figures but as for doing what LBC do and
allowing their presenters to do what are
sometimes violently opinionated columns
on air as it were express their opinions
unreservedly I think that would destroy
the BBC I know it would be absolutely in
my view absolutely unacceptable we don't
have a perfect system but it's if we've
got presenters like Emily have to be as
I was have to be a scene to be to the
extent that it's humanly possible have
to be seen to be impartial other words
the BBC cannot be trusted the BBC has
only one currency and that's trust know
that if we have a situation which I
think you may be getting out we're
increasingly other major broadcasters as
their business model of opinionated
stuff can the BBC survive as the sole
place where they're not opinionated
because aren't people gonna say of the
BBC oh you're just as opinionated but
you're hiding your opinion for five
there is an argument that says it can't
I phrase it slightly differently you can
get to this look you guys new people own
the BBC you pay your licence fee and
without it statement of the obvious the
BBC cannot resist if you want an
opinionated BBC you would make that
let's just try it let's just try and
stick your hands up if you believe that
people like Justin not me people like
Justin should be allowed for the know
just a straight question all unqualified
but but just stick out of if you believe
people like Justin should be allowed to
express views on air
even about racism I wouldn't allow that
do you see because of racism is against
the law we're against murder we're
against rich yes no but that's a that's
a no no that is an assisting there are
all sorts of things that are against the
law but that still doesn't mean that you
on air that people here want people on
air to be saying yeah I think it's a
terrible thing no no but we are allowed
if somebody commits a dreadful dreadful
heinous crime we are allowed to say that
man was evil or whatever and no who
would argue with that you know who would
argue that but that somebody who murders
first now I think the issue is not so
much what we're running the Perez John
says everything we write in the papers
as BBC people is is is read and
eventually it's better what we write on
social media isn't and that is that the
next frontier for the election I think
the BBC is gonna have to well you
brother
oddly for a youngster like yourself
you've rather stayed away from social
media budget why not
Twitter obviously does a lot of useful
valuable things but the price we pay for
it is a rather nasty form of mob rule
and when when when women MPs are being
threatened with rape and the kind of
foul stuff really really vile stuff it
appears on the Twittersphere that's I
don't feel the need to read it people
want to express opinions to each other
fine let them so long as they are not
illegal that is to say if they espouse
racism then they've got to be shut up
BBC people should be on Twitter I would
probably you can't stop them because
it's become a how many games forgive me
for doing this but John you could stop
them say to BBC reporters not you're a
reporter for the BBC it's a privileged
position don't be on social media and
then and then they would I think be
entitled to say the rest of the world is
on Twitter from the President of the
United States down why should we
uniquely be banned from engaging in that
public discourse I think what you do and
this is what the BBC does is says they
say use Twitter
but if you abuse it sometimes happens
then you'll be disciplined and if
necessary you'll be cycling and that's
how I think it should be all right well
it's a fascinating question I think
number four
come in number four here we go hello I
wanted to ask you about balance which is
obviously slightly different to the
question of impartiality and
particularly around editorial decisions
and balance over controversial topics
especially political ones
I'd be really interested to hear what
you think about whether the BBC always
gets balanced right what do you mean by
balance sorry to interrogate you but
when you talk about balance what do you
mean by balance because it is quite a
complicated concept of them yeah I agree
I think so there are two types of
balance that I'm interested in hearing
your views on one is about the balance
between political parties during
electoral campaigns and where you sit in
the polls versus your priority in terms
of being put on air and then secondarily
on issues where there are is an
asymmetric view say climate change and
and/or racism which is not an opinion
it's a bits of fact but the need to
present a balance of two arguments for
the purposes of radio you might have
somebody who supports the racist view
and doesn't support a racist view and
that that is a not a reflection of the
true balance of opinion right yeah I'm
taking one well I think it's perfectly
straightforward and it has happened to
me I've had somebody on the program who
was allegedly an influential figure in
his community who started spouting
racist stuff to me as part of the tempo
state sequence and I shut him up and we
got rid of him people are not allowed to
use the BBC above all BBC news
programmes and sometimes it happens in
comedy and maybe sometimes in live
exchanges it's impossible but as far as
the BBC news programmes are concerned
people are not allowed to use
BBC news programs as a platform for
racist views full stop no no no
qualification there at all as far as
something like global warming is
concerned we know as a matter of fact
now that global warming threatens the
future of this planet I don't think I
don't know maybe lots of you would
disagree with that
that is my informed view and mercifully
it's the view that should be able to
disagree with it beyond well not given
it's it's it's an immensely difficult
one it would it would have to depend a
bit I think it look let's assume and
this is such an unlikely scenario that
it's sort of his ducking a question in a
way but let's assume that the most
senior scientist let's just let's take a
really very silly example let's assume
that the bloke who was awarded today
yesterday
yesterday I think the the Nobel Prize
for his party physics Nobel Prize of
science and he with his credentials
professor of bomb Obama and winner of
the Nobel Prize said I got great
concerns as to the veracity of global MA
you would have to report those views of
course you would but if a politician or
a former camp or a sympathizer of the
oil companies or whatever express those
views no I don't think they're entitled
because the overwhelming weight of
evidence the overwhelming weight of
evidence is now again if it wasn't a few
if you'd ask me this question ten years
ago I'd have said hmm well there are an
awful lot of people who would question
but so longer the case and so you
wouldn't have on climate skeptics at all
I probably wouldn't I mean you'd have to
you'd have to construct a can't what
scenario can you imagine in which we
should have was you know quite recently
we had al gore on and later in the
program Nigel I interviewed him and I I
failed to correct something he said that
wasn't true and we we were overrun we've
got a
going over for it and and but what a lot
of people objected to actually and I
think this goes to what you're asked is
what why do we have them on at all and
and you're saying in those circumstances
we shouldn't know I think probably not
what about gay rights we have enormous
pressure from some social conservatives
who say we are being airbrushed out of
modern life if you sincerely believe
that homosexuality is a sin should you
be allowed to express that on air on The
Today program or not
yes I believe you should why do you have
a difference between that and climate
change one is a provable scientific fact
climate change is a provable scientific
fact and ninety five percent whatever it
is how do you get to these figures
ninety five ninety nine maybe percent of
the world's climate scientists agree and
that's good enough for me and it
therefore should be I think good enough
for our there is no real question I
think there's no real question that
people are born gay it's a thing and
what gay people say is that's not what's
actually scientifically the case live
with it and you may not have people and
there are people inside let me let me
put frame the question yeah who believe
really strongly that it is no longer
acceptable for other people to come on
and say actually and question them and
question them as people and questioned
who they are the differences between
doubting facts scientific provable
scientific facts and having a belief
yeah so if and this is slightly changing
the ground a little bit but if for
instance you have a bloke with the
sandwich board on the street and saying
the end of the world is nigh and if
you've got another book with a fine you
know whatever and and you've got another
bloke saying or homosexual should be
locked up that is completely
unacceptable obviously that is not
allowed if you have somebody who as a
matter of deep profound
belief feels that we have we should not
be allowing exactly the same rights is
the wrong word and I'm trying I'm
struggling a bit with with the wood if
somebody if you are a a Christian with
serious beliefs who genuinely feels that
Jesus would have been a Christian God
did not want people of the same sex to
get married which will not do they are
allowed to express that view they should
they are I mean there's no question but
they are allowed the law doesn't stop it
yeah and they're on that and then you
want an avalanche and they are they are
allowed to fester what we should not be
doing in my view and it's kind of the
other side of the case the corner where
we appointed an LGBT correspondent some
while ago who after his appointment made
a little film for the BBC for the
website BBC website in which he said
that he regarded himself I'm truncating
it obviously as a mouthpiece for the gay
community in my view is that he
shouldn't be we don't have no we don't
have mouthpieces for any other community
do we and I'm deeply deeply uneasy about
that that's slightly different though
from this issue that the lady at the top
and I and I think you know from John's
answers and and these are discussions
that the BBC of course has and they
change over time the only thing that
seekers believe the big difference is
but is between belief but three things
right racism no place it's against the
law apart from anything else and I think
every I would like to think every
civilized person in the land regards it
as being against gay peoples against the
law yes
and and we can't do that we absolutely
can't do that but you might have but you
see we're gonna have someone on who says
I think we should well you'll still have
people on who believe that their
religion tells them that yeah but then
but if they came on and said you know
gay people shouldn't be allowed to be
teachers then yeah I'm out of town on a
rail but there is a difference I think
between a genuinely held religious
belief and being allowed to express it
and we went to four before we went to
three which is all wrong anyway yeah
here we go yeah there's been a great
deal of discussion about the decline of
civility in politics in the public
square do you think that is in fact the
case or have we simply become more
sensitive over the past say ten years
well I wasn't actually in the audience
but I can remember nigh bevin calling
the Tory sewer rats or know that lower
than vermin I think was was his
expression wasn't it so I tend that was
quite a few years ago
they've always abused each other is it
much worse now I'm not sure it is to be
honest I mean they're behaving pretty
stupidly in Parliament but then there's
nothing new about that is there and they
are they are they more disrespectful of
each other than they used to be I'm not
sure that they are you hint at one stage
in the book they're interviewing styles
like yours and you think back to Robin
day and Alastair Burnett and the people
who kind of changed the style that
actually that in a sense has coarsened
I think it might have done I think it
might have done you I set down some
responsibilities yeah you're sad yeah
the trouble is we were on a journey in a
very real sense we're on a journey we
were we were kind of on a front from
Robin day and other than that before
them as as we all know it a typically
tough question would be have you
anything else to say to a grateful
nation Minister and and we've moved on a
bit from that and it's and it's probably
what would how shall we start minister
shall we start with helm affairs or
Foreign Affairs for that's a jolly good
decision yes I mean it happened it
actually did happen and we moved on a
wee bit from that and we move too far
possibly but but only a very very timid
possibly because I think we are already
beginning to adjust ourselves as it were
I when I started doing it when I joined
the Today programme I thought
that it was incumbent on me to be rough
and tough and aggressive more arrested
and I went over the top in the early
days I can remember I lost my temper a
few times absolutely unforgivable should
be allowed and and I think you you may
or may not agree this ordinary behind
the scene but up but I think that I have
personally since you asked it personally
I think that I've become more laid-back
would that do well well a bit how about
a bit less aggressive all right I'd was
settled that I I think I went through a
period I was a young man I went through
a period where I was probably too
aggressive too much of the time and I
think I probably did interrupt too much
I think now I mean then I'm no longer
there am i I don't interrupt as much as
many other people I think there are many
other interviewers who interrupt rather
more than I did or did recently and and
it annoys me so when I hear it annoys
you when you hear engineers when I hear
people interrupting too much so you
don't get the answer I like to think
obviously I would say this wouldn't I I
like to think that I interrupted only
when being completely pure only only
when the minister or whoever it was was
refusing to answer the question or even
was pretending they'd already answered
the question and everybody could yeah
that's all I like to think that then if
they were going off deliberately in a
fault then I would stop them but but
maybe yeah yeah and it's that still that
should still be the rule for those of us
who are still doing it that the
interruptions come when someone has been
asked a question the question is obvious
and they are obviously not answering it
then you are entitled otherwise you end
up with a series of party political
broadcasts and nobody well nobody will
listen apart from anything else so we
have a responsibility to hold their feet
to the fire so long as we do it with a
certain politeness I don't think we're
allowed to shout at them okay over there
number two
now yeah go on say whatever number you
are you know Justin how long do you have
to prepare for an interview and has
there ever been a time when you thought
I am very good oh yes
yes a very good question yes well the
one classic one I mean they aren't the
font of the things I said how long do
you have to prepare sometimes no time at
all I mean quite literally no time at
all I can remember on one occasion when
the the steering was crashing in the
studio I mean literally falling apart of
the radio cars weren't turning up the
machines were breaking though and we
were down it was about twenty to nine so
we have 20 minutes of airtime left to
fill and nothing to fill it with and we
were all panicking like mad the last
tape was finally running out so in about
30 seconds nothing to put on the air and
then somebody came in but the studio
producer came into my ear and said we've
got the leader of the Indian opposition
on the line
[Laughter]
and and and what what I wanted to say
was yes and why and who is he and and
that was it because then I was live on
air with the leader of the Indian
opposition and I did I did one time I'm
actually quite per who do this because
leaders of opposition's had one thing in
common they all want to drop loads of
dirt on the leader of the government
because that's why they're the leader
and so so I took a chance and I said
it's seems like a pretty serious state
of affairs in yoga and then he said well
you see this here but and then we would
away so that was so that was the the
other one that was was so easy in that
was was when at 25 to 7:00 in the
morning and and the studio producer came
in I just done an interview with the
chap called Gennady grass him off it was
at the time the most senior figure in
the in the venn Soviet government in
Moscow and and I done interview with him
and the studio producer came into my
headphones and said and bear in mind
this was the day we were talking about
this earlier the days when producers on
the Today programme weren't how can we
put this politely entirely sober all
through the night occasionally
occasionally anyway he came in way and
he said we go Margaret Thatcher on the
line for you and I thought yeah right
and the next second I heard mr. Humphrey
is good morning
and see imagine that happening today in
these we've got controlled the times
she'd been in the kitchen number 10
making self company literally and and
she heard what I would say there and she
said she told the switchboard put me
through to mr. Humphries and and they
found that stood there anyway there we
are and there she was so I said well as
who since since we've got you might as
well talk to you about other things as
well no and she said no and I remember
to remember Bernard Ingham her yeah
chief information or press office or
whatever
very anyway he he told me years later
that he'd he'd been driving into work
when he heard that exchange and he said
and I only say we got that I heard voice
I nearly drove off the [ __ ] Road I
didn't answer your question the answer
is most of the time if it's a seriously
if it's an interview with the Prime
Minister
you usually get you'll know about it
ahead of time so you'll have maybe a few
hours the day before to prepare or
usually if it's somebody as senior as
that maybe if it's charging their phones
maybe you'll know but not necessarily as
often as not you will have virtually no
ton of it and and the other problem is
that if you go to bed as you do well in
my case anyway I used to go to bed at
half-past eight get of it up or three
you're not going to be able to be
informed about what's happened in
Parliament over the last whatever it is
and so on and so so there'll be a huge
amount you don't know and and often you
are not prepared you haven't been
brilliant not because we like to live
dangerously but just it just doesn't
work like that on it did on a program
like today different if you're doing
world at one for obvious reasons but on
today you're often pretty much flying
blind which is what you have a first
question written down no no do you know
what it is no again so Sara Lee and
that's very stupid I I cannot defend
that I can tell myself that it's
actually by having no questions written
down it's it enables you to have a
proper conversation so you can respond
to what the person has just said to you
and you can carry out and that's really
the really the right way to do it
the truth is that
just can't do it I mean I don't know
about you but you know go in at 4
o'clock look at the running order and
then find 27 different reasons for not
bothering to you know yeah I mean yeah
we're didn't it and you know it's stupid
you know that if you're going to
interview so-and-so at 10 past 8:00 you
should be worrying about that and
planning at all and say and you do if
you find anything to do there's that bit
of lint in the corner of the computer
screen I you know oh yeah
matters right in the middle yes number
four thank you
given that you've been at the heart of
the news and if we put climate change as
an existential threat to one side what
do you think the greatest threat to the
UK is now I am well I think to the world
is a potential catastrophic
technological breakdown I think that is
got to be considered real if we're going
to have I mean do I know your guess is
as good as mine but the reliance that
all of us have now every single
individual human being except the tiny
babies I suppose has on the technicians
of the technical whiz kids getting it
right is absolutely terrifying and the
ability for the other but the people who
want to cause mayhem or want to become
terribly rich by blackmailing this or
that or rogue state powers or simply
rogue terrorists who want a cause is
great and I'm not sure that we have the
wherewithal in every sense
intellectual technical material the
wherewithal to combat that if it were to
happen because it would be so damned
Swift that the system would break down I
mean they say that there's three days
supply of food in in the supermarkets
for instance and supermarkets cannot
survive cannot operate the way they
operate without their computers and if
the thing breaks down God knows will
view and then many many many even more
Susan it I think probably that's what's
what's your personal relationship with
technology not not proven not term
I will not threaten Bill Gates let's put
it like that I am who you ask computers
I mean when I first when I first joined
the today program I reveal this to you
because they're not sure John's gonna
get that but John used to we have
computers in the studio the first thing
John would come in and rather over
violently put the computer down so that
he couldn't see the screen but now you
do use the screen you're on a journey
yeah I won't hurt him yeah pretty soon
have you got you got these phones no
that don't have to here yeah no no lines
wires to join them up yeah you are a
user of Technology though you're not
you're not oh no no no but I really
didn't think that computers helped in
the early days and what people were
doing and we had a particular colleague
I won't mention his name but he spent
half the program when you could do this
sort of thing and it was unusual to be
able to do it on the computer booking
his holidays uh stuff well and you know
who it is
yeah yeah if I were a journalist worth
my soul though I would press you on who
it was but actually I'm not going to the
song right at the very top there though
next to number four and then we'll come
down this side as well yeah Thank You
Justin hello John I'm John on the record
was a great program it was axed and I
was very sad about that that's where I
first saw you my question and you've
touched on the answer to this question
and that is about politicians the
quality of politicians in Britain today
and indeed America what's your view on
that
what's your view and also who are the
best three sorry who are the who are the
best three politicians in the last 30
years in the UK or the US and who are
the worst three on the record piece
I think there's probably a bit too much
in there for the remaining minutes that
we've got left but I am NOT absolutely
convinced that politicians are any worse
than they ever have been with this
exception that a few years ago and it's
not that very long ago there was a wider
spread of different sorts of people in
the House of Commons I mean if there's a
little while ago but nonetheless there
was a time when we had trade union
representatives ood worked in factories
when we had lots of teachers when we had
lots of people who were not part of the
political scene now it's becoming
vanishingly unlikely your path into
politics now is you leave University you
go and become a SPAD or an assistant
deputy SPAD special advisor and then you
stand in line patiently and a seat
becomes vacant and you apply for the
seaton you join the House of Commons so
you have too many people who all look
and sound alike I mean in the sense of
their you know the way they approach
politics and and they are I think
somewhat isolated there aren't enough
people who know also cliche but there
aren't enough people who know what makes
ordinary people tick that that's that's
what what is me then name those who do
and those who don't
that's what he wants yeah well it's very
very difficult we haven't had a prime
minister since John Major who was part
of that other group now the major you
approval I didn't say that I because I'm
because he wasn't a very effective prime
minister in in so many ways Thatcher
well you couldn't but argue that
Thatcher made a huge impact on this
country
you can certainly argue about some of
the decisions she took of course you
could there are two in the book there
are two in the book Ken Clark yeah and
Robin Cook yeah but it's fair to say
both of those you like and admire as
people i am i admired admired robin cook
a because he was terribly bright and
incidentally was also
aware overly aware in my view of the
figure that he cut on the public stage
we were we were standing in the gents
loo at one point after we it was John
Smith had just died as leader of the
Labour Party he was running who was
going to be the new leader at the Labour
Party and it was Robin Cook Tony Blair
Gordon Brown those were the three and
but but none of them had actually thrown
their hat into the ring at that stage
and I would we were standing and washing
our hands and with a mirror in front of
us and I said and I said to Robin
because he wouldn't say I tried to get
him on the programme to say and he
wouldn't and I said come on Robin even
tell me now you're gonna have a go at
the leadership aren't you and he said no
I'm not I'm not I'm really not and I
said why because he's a very bright man
and courageous do you remember he
resigned over the Iraq war the only one
to do so at that stage pleasure short
came later but anyway he said I said why
why not your abaya he said look in the
mirror look at that face pointing this
way I'm too ugly and I thought that was
terribly sad so I rated him hugely and
yes I read Ken Clark because partly
because he has a sense of humor he
doesn't take himself too seriously in
lots of ways but also because he is
filling me bright and he does have a
sense of what ordinary people in the
street freeze my question is if you were
able to give the controller of radio for
some advice to in guarantee its future
in a world of increasing media streams
with podcasts and Netflix and another
channel every week what would those
words of wisdom be I wish I had some do
you know what I think they'd be and
you'll be very disappointed with this
answer don't worry too much about what
they're doing on social media for
instance or indeed what any anybody else
is doing radio for exists and prospers
and I know what you're going to say
young people aren't switching on and
that is a danger but radio 4 exists to
be an intelligent voice
appealing to a certain group of people
and that is always going to be the case
it will always be a certain section of
the population it has always been will
always be a certain section a pretty
broad section in many cases certainly
further than these programs on radio 4
but what we cannot do in my advice the
idea they live but anyway my advice
would be don't it's not a race to the
bottom don't engage in a race to the
bottom don't look at social media and
say oh this is the way you get there
kids because it's not when I joined the
program 33 years ago they said they were
quite open about you they said they'd
given me the job because I was young
imagine that being young and and we had
we absolutely did the radio for April an
especially had to appeal to younger
people because they were but you know
what happens
younger people get older and then they
die and other younger people come along
and so on and there is this kind of
circle and we still I mean when I joined
the program and I'd like to say this
entirely down to me it might not have
been entirely down to me when I joined
the program there were 4 million
listeners we now have 7 million and the
fact is that's because young people are
not as thick as lots of us say they are
they're actually pretty bloody bright
and a lot of them do listen to the radio
for albeit on differently that's fine
got to sit there with a wireless set in
front of them obviously and they listen
on the phone and whatever but they will
listen if we're offering them the right
material and we've got to stay serious
that's the thing radio 4 is for serious
listeners or is there's no point that is
that is a wonderful moment a wonderful
thought with which to end I love it that
you still say we do this I know you know
you when I interview ever going to stop
he wants to mention master because he
wants you to know that he hasn't retired
okay they hasn't retired you can meet
him now and he'll sign a book for you I
think you're gonna do that I assume out
at the front it's not gonna be happening
here I can't say any books here can I
just say it has been the honor of my
lifetime to sit next to you for the last
10 years you're not a perfect person
you're not a perfect interviewer but you
are one of the most extraordinary and
dynamic people I've ever met and it's a
real pleasure John
Kenneth
what I'm sorry about home I agree with
every word of that except except that it
applies to him he's absolutely plug here
thank you very much
[Applause]